the earth you may know it as that blue
thing Bruce Willis is always trying to
save or from its famous collaboration
with wind and fire or just simply as
that place where George Clooney lives
anyway
the earth had some genuinely bad news
this week a White House report that says
global warming threatens every part of
the US this isn't something in the
distant future climate change is already
affecting us now now
smart move Obama that is a key shift in
how to talk about climate change because
we've all proven that we cannot be
trusted with the future tense
we've been repeatedly asked don't you
want to leave a better earth for your
grandchildren and we've all collectively
responded fuck'em but incredibly this
latest damning scientific report may
still face an uphill climb with some of
us there's that Gallup poll that came
out last month which found one in four
Americans is skeptical of all the
effects of climate change and thinks
this issues been exaggerated who gives a
that doesn't matter
you don't need people's opinions on a
fact you might as well have a poll
asking which number is bigger 15 or 5 or
do owls exist or are their hats
the debate on climate change should not
be whether or not it exists it's what we
should do about it there is a mountain
of research on this topic global
temperatures are rising heat waves are
becoming more common sea surface
temperatures are also rising glaciers
are melting and of course no climate
report is complete without the
obligatory photo of a polar bear
balancing on a piece of ice